and now on to the border of insanity and
that is the focus of tonight's angle the
reaction to last night's show from Del
Rio border sector was so overwhelming we
just couldn't let it go now we brought
you video you had not seen before along
the Rio Grande River the natural barrier
between Mexico and the United States in
this part of Texas well we saw
immigrants illegal immigrants jumping
into the river from the Mexico side with
full knowledge that nearby border patrol
would jump in and rescue them
so what will you do here there's a
father annotation device No
so he's in the water without the babies
got the got the device all right
I'll get over here
this is terrifying I mean if a man
separated now you have a man separated
from his baby here the baby's crying on
the other boat and Border Patrol is left
to have to fish him out of the river we
don't want to become a ferry service all
right we know that it's a daily struggle
that these guys have but you know you
can't you can't leave an infant in the
water i struggling you can't leave small
turn and leaving in the water it was
terrifying but a ferry service is
exactly what the Border Patrol has
become now the legal eagles may be
indigent and they only come with what
they can fit in a little grocery bag but
they're extremely well informed of our
loopholes and our absurd enforcement
restrictions and now they're taking
advantage of all of those loopholes with
the help of the cartels who get this are
paid handsomely by the illegals to help
transport them across Mexico and right
into the hands of our Border Patrol now
here you see people cheering on the
shoreline after this man is pulled onto
the boat who is that Guinness Guinness
the Guinness I don't get it right amigos
now I spoke with some of these migrants
and they come as I said with little to
nothing and along with their children
who are innocent pawns and all of this
and the sadness and the fear in their
eyes I will not forget but everyone I
spoke to everyone already has a place in
the United States to go but not just to
Maryland we got snow star-spangled and
Amiga it's that kind of Washington
Washington well I told that particular
migrant though that was I was from we
had a little moment of levity but
politicians have been downplaying this
for political reasons we all know that
they're lying to you this is a national
problem it's not just a border state
problem one of the more illuminating
moments from yesterday was in the border
patrol processing center now they didn't
let us bring cameras in to the area
where they're actually processing the
illegal immigrants for privacy and other
concerns but they're taken to this
processing center after they're picked
up in the Rio Grande now inside they're
separated into categories family units
single adult males and unaccompanied
minors now the families that I spoke
with told me that they had paid the
cartels up to $12,000 for passage but
guess what the money in most cases came
from relatives or friends already in the
US and it gets better
most of them are illegals - you heard
that right our system is so screwed up
that it permits illegals living here now
to finance the trips of other illegals
who want to come join them oh and it
gets worse we have folks who will come
in and literally within 45 minutes
they're in a delivery room and that was
just a week ago when they're delivering
chill
they're delivering children we will
apprehend them there'll be eight and a
half nine months pregnant and they'll be
in labor when we make that arrest by the
time we get to the emergency room
they're delivering within 30 to 45
minutes
and guess who picks up the costs at the
hospital well we all do
taxpayers here in the United States are
subsidizing
the enormous cost of health care for
illegal immigrants their children and
their births once here now I found out
today that in 2018 alone Memorial
Hermann health system here in Texas the
largest healthcare provider in the Lone
Star State reported almost half a
billion dollars in losses due to unpaid
medical bills they basically had to
write it all off well of course since
you know they don't get paid and they're
not authorized by the way to ask
patients about their immigration status
ultimately the cost is eventually passed
on to well you guessed it Americans so I
ask you how is any of this acceptable we
have u.s. vets who still can't get the
timely treatment they need
yet illegal immigrants are allowed to
use emergency rooms as their primary
care centers free of charge it's obscene
and it's unfair but you still don't
think it's an emergency right well
tonight we learn from our sources in the
Rio Grande Valley sector that they are
being completely overrun by
unprecedented numbers of illegal aliens
and asylum seekers over the past week
and this stunned me 10,000 illegal
aliens were apprehended by Border Patrol
those are just the ones apprehended and
that made it one of the highest weekly
totals ever seen in the history of this
sector new numbers for the month of
April are coming out tomorrow and
sources are telling us that they could
be the highest on record my friends this
is a complete and total travesty we
spent trillions of dollars in Iraq and
Afghanistan defending other people's
borders and we've allowed our own
borders to just become meaningless any
politician who says this
in a crisis or refuses to be part of a
real solution should retire or be
retired and that's the angle